tempted by the Titans end graphics card
but put off by its $3,000 price tag
want to show your console owning friends
what 4k gaming actually looks like well
rejoice because AMD has unveiled the
295x2 a $1500 graphics card that they
say is the world's fastest I'm mark
Walton and this is a GameSpot news
update just weeks after Nvidia announced
its GTX Titan said graphics card AMD has
unleashed the AMD Radeon r9 295x2 which
costs just fifteen hundred dollars it's
due for release on April 21st the liquid
called GPU features 5632 stream
processors 352 texture units 4k display
support 8 gigabytes of gddr5 memory a
new sexy metal enclosure and 11.5
teraflops of compute power that's over 6
times that compute power of the ps4 and
almost 9 times as much as the Xbox one
early reviews are indeed confirming the
card world's fastest GPU status
particularly at high resolutions like
1440p and 4k
it's a powerful card then but you'll
need quite the rig to power it with it
running at a 500 watt minimum it does at
least run cool with a new liquid cooling
system keeping it at around 60 degrees
under load is AMD's latest graphics card
going to find a home in your gaming PC
or is $1,500 overkill and if you do get
one will you rub your console owning
friends noses in it let us know in the
comments below and for more of the
latest gaming news keep it GameSpot
you